new in theaters this weekend - like a
boss under water 1917 and just mercy
what will you see this is your weekend
ticket women four hundred and
ninety-three thousand dollars in debt
when to make up company entrepreneurs
run into financial troubles they strike
up a dream 1 million dollar deal with a
major beauty mogul but it isn't long
before her mentoring turns to
backstabbing leading the two friends
turned business partners to step up and
take her down punch that [ __ ] in the
face I would marry you if I was in the
coochie this movies for you if you're
looking for a comedy this weekend
you like the antics of Tiffany Haddish
and Rose Byrne or you've ever tried to
start a business with your friend my
friend and I were going to start a
French frys only restaurant yeah
and underwater that's the movie crew
suffers critical damage on their vessel
after a strange earthquake now they must
resort to a desperate escape that
unfortunately puts them up against
whatever was the earthquake this movies
for you if a horror suspense movie
sounds good to you you'll have a good
monster movie or if like me you have
Dallas a phobia don't worry it's not
continuous there's only one way this
ends
Last Man Standing now when it's wider
release 1917 is the tale of two British
soldiers tasked with the mission of
delivering vital information of an
upcoming ambush across dangerous
territory in World War one the movie is
filmed to give the impression that it's
one long take from beginning to end
meant to give a realistic ticking clock
feeling and it just picked up two Golden
Globe wins including one for Best Motion
Picture in the drama category this movie
is for you if a realistic war movie
sounds good this weekend you're excited
to see the much acclaimed cinematography
or you realize the real battlefield is
love and I'm gonna do everything
possible to keep them from taking you
all know what you into down here now
better when you get it from the moment
you're born we don't you and another
film that's in theaters everywhere this
weekend is just mercy a film about a
driven fledgling lawyer set to a
volatile case who must defend a man
wrongfully accused of the murder of an
18 year old girl in 1987 Alabama this
movies for you if a based on a true
story movie sounds good to you you're a
fan of the solid acting of Michael B
Jordan and Jamie Foxx or if you're a
support main player in overwatch at
least one person is gonna get that I
hope that is your weekend ticket will
you see and check back next week for
Will Smith and Robert Downey jr. but not
in the same movie yes